i like it how joss whedon referred to
himself as a maverick
he said in the beginning he was sort of
the company man or
maybe i'm paraphrasing here but and then
he became more of a maverick so you
think it's more that type people that
are
they're willing to conform a little bit
but at some point
sort of that um this is my show has to
come out that that whole ownership
well in doss's instance in that
particular quote he was
referring to the fact that he was
perceived as a maverick because he had
spoken out against the networks
on a certain number of occasions which
were less than one hand you could count
them on
um but because he had spoken out in
those those particular times
he had somehow found out that he'd
earned a reputation as this
maverick but in reality he's actually
very much a company man
and tries to choice to be a company man
but as far as personality types we've
seen
such a breadth and scope of personality
types from very quiet and
and measured and
cerebral um two very very gregarious
and and over the top and you know so as
far as like
type a type b i wouldn't say that's so
much the case but confidence
um having a creative vision having
something to say
um and being confident enough to step up
and and uh
take the reins and manage you know the
the execution of that vision
is in immensely important um but
being able to make decisions whether
right or wrong but being decisive
and intentional deliberate in your
actions and
having that with that vision in mind is
is of utmost importance because if you
don't have that then someone's going to
come in and fill that gap
it's going to create a vacuum of power
of vision and of authority and
administration and everything in between
so
if someone rushes in to fill that vacuum
they can compromise your creative vision
you